In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinexadion for June 22, on which we commemorate the Holy Proto-Marter
Albin of Britain.
Saint Albin was a pagan of modest origins who lived in Verolamium, Saint Albin's, and
who offered hospitality to a missionary priest who was fleeing his persecutors.
When Albin saw his guest persevering in prayer day and night, he was touched by divine grace
and began to follow his example, questioning him about his faith.
The teaching of the Holy Priest drove all trace of idolatrous superstition from his heart,
and he received the illumination of holy baptism.
The Roman governor was informed that the missionary priest was hiding in Albin's house,
and he sent soldiers to the house to arrest him.
When they arrived, they found Albin dressed in the priest's robes, but the priest had fled.
He put up no resistance when seized, and was taken before the tribunal just at the moment
when the judge was about to offer sacrifice to the false gods.
Besides himself with rage in realizing that he had been tricked, the magistrate threatened
Albin with death, unless he handed over the fugitive and offered sacrifice to the gods.
When he was asked about his identity, Albin proudly replied that he was henceforth a Christian,
both in name and manner of life, and he mocked the inanimate idols, which could neither
answer those who worshipped and offered prayer to them, but would rather cause the eternal
damnation of their devotees.
The judge handed him over to his soldiers to be beaten without mercy, but as the saint showed
the endurance of an incorporal being and was radiant with joy, the judge ordered that
he be executed without delay.
It is said that, by his prayer, Saint Albin allowed the crowd who came to be present at
his execution to cross the river Kondrashad, not to delay his entrance into heaven by having
to wait until they had all passed across the narrow bridge that led to the scaffold.
One of his executioners was converted by this miracle, and declared that he was ready
to be beheaded in the saint's place.
Dragged to the top of a high hill, Albin, through his prayer, caused a spring to gush forth,
so that the crowd might quench its thirst.
He prayed for his persecutors, and then, peacefully, surrendered himself to the sword.
At the moment at which the saint's head fell to the ground, the eyes of his executioner
fell out of their sockets.
Before such a spectacle, the governor ordered that the persecution cease, and that due honor
be paid to the glorious martyrs of Christ.
From that time, many sick people found healing at Saint Albin's tomb, and his venerations spread
throughout England, where he is venerated as the first martyr of that country, as well
as in the rest of Europe.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.